du boeuf sur moi quand je sais pas mais
non non c'est pas moi c'est ça c'est pas
toi chose mecheri merci en tout cas
d'être avec nous alors il ya des
comédiens formidables dans l'équipe et
ce soir on aimerait rejouer des scènes
de premiers baisers vous allez nous dire
qu'ils sont pour vous qui est pour vous
le meilleur comédien de tp on en a
sélectionné six il ya un premier duo qui
va composé d'isabelle morini bosc et doc
gynéco un deuxième de jean michel et
maxime et un troisième de mathieu et
qu'elle est prête à les remettre
ludivine ah non je n'aime pas dans ce
nom mathieu lula da silva a sélectionné
deux premiers couples qui mois de
qualifier ensuite pour la demi-finale
d'accord a démarré avec mathieu
christine alors viens viens on donné le
caractère et c'est parce que j'étais
parti pour refaire la même si je sais
pas peut-être à tous ces partis on vient
de le voir non pas tellement fou mais
ses mains js bach jean-michel au flipper
ouais mais tu fais comment bah je sais
pas c'est avec mon talent qu'est ce que
tu fais ce soir à faire quel talent
c'est une très belle
c'est fait ouais en bresse moi j'ai
préféré embrasser saint michel
mais tu es un gars ou l'autre acteur qui
a les cheveux gris c'est jouer ses
jeunes ses voiles et enfin c'est une
catastrophe et de trucs mais les deux
c'est une capacité ne cadraient les
gérer et maxime à 18 ans vivent à
grenoble bien sûr les gens me suis
occupé en ce moment je sais pas ce qui
m'arrive est championne les cours
ça n'arrête pas entre la nous laisse par
terre tu te laisses noms qui me laisse
porter elle monte sur moi et mes le
m'écrase par la même occasion à changer
ton slip taupin près depuis l'espagne et
à l'euro ce serait une grande
non non c'est le sprint bleu tu sais que
toi ici jamais rien passé entre ou
encore non et pourquoi pas ce que tu
aies jamais proposé quoi que ce soit je
veux
[Applaudissements]
maxime attention yabou faire attention
au bouclage et de co2 jean est qu ici on
a peu de temps là
ah oui ça va faire un sacré bout de
temps
et alors il paraît que tu as quelque
chose à me when résilient j'adore se
dégrader de montres tous des gratuits
mois et en quoi est ce col mao col du
fémur échancrée à celle effectuée tant
que je suis le 22 août à chemise je suis
de porter une chute je venais pas une
raison précise cesseront avis oui je
voulais dire un truc à tes lèvres
vasini ils enclenchent je verrai après
si j'accepte vas-y mais avant moi le
baiser que je t'ai donné avant moi le
baiser que je t'ai donné ça swinguait
mais pas d'or
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est gallas et j'adore aussi fort
dans ses formes
je vous le dis anthony et madison il
pour moi les bons mois les deux couples
qualifiés union maxime et gens me et doc
gynéco et isabelle attention deuxième
set j'ai à offrir
je pense que maxime doit faire françois
bien sûr et bien sûr janvier dans un
giro vais te la fais plus de place
attention à ce que vous vous rappelez de
cette histoire ouais à isis partie sais
pas où vous arrivez à vous arrivez vous
êtes énervé tribalisme
elle m'a fait chier et tu te laisses
journée celle là est ce que j'ai entendu
dire quoi mais avec du boeuf sur moi
quand je suis pas là mais non non c'est
pas moi c'est toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention il est donc alors on doit
chercher cet objet déco qui doit servir
et françois fait françois alors
attention doc gynéco vallée mais qu'est
ce que tu dis là
alors tu dois tu énervé parce que à la
palapa ranger ta chambre
c'est maxime hématies mes jambes mais
merci quand même temps non mais c'est
pas grave
qu est-ce qu enfin je te connais si tu
viens là m'emmerder loach est en train
de jouer au flipper c'est que tu as un
truc qui me déplaît alors dit ne sommes
pas je te baadhio en fait non il y avait
dans la chambre rien tout va bien mais
je te connais alphonse to connect
françois margolin
quand quand il vient comme ça c'est que
qu'un truc de travers alors ça va durer
toute la soirée tu vas le faire mais
google crève l'abcès
mais crève l'abcès
[Rires]
alors merci à isabelle et docks
alors franchement annette vous appelle
and alors antonio à magali et anthony a
eu magali vous dites quoi bah écoute là
quand même là c'est la jambe c'est
incroyable
et pour moi jamie est le meilleur tomber
la gamme et on est d'accord j'en ai 28
[Musique]